[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a week five review of johnny depp versus
amber heard this was a a multi-day
assault that took place over three
horrible days the worst thing ever
we're not talking
cross-examination gets tense when amber
heard takes a stand and amber heard's
sister corroborates her story he strikes
me in the back i hear amber shout don't
hit my sister
she smacks him plus do you
know
whether mr depp
is being considered for a role in
pirates six i don't know one way or the
other a disney executive addresses
depp's future with the pirates franchise
and whether herd's op-ed affected his
role and later i
looked through
uh tweets that were negative towards
misheard and i found
that
a super majority of them were using one
of four different hashtags
herd's team calls their own expert to
testify about the ex-spouse's reputation
online law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
i'm your host brian buckmeyer week five
of the johnny depp versus amber heard
defamation trial has wrapped up as
closing arguments loom just days ahead
after a week-long break from the case
court reconvened with heard on the stand
her testimony comes as part of a
multi-million dollar defamation suit
stemming from her 2018 washington post
op-ed about domestic violence while depp
was never mentioned in the article he
argues readers know he was publicly
linked to heard depp filed a 50 million
dollar lawsuit claiming damages but
heard shot back with a hundred million
dollar suit doubling down on her
domestic violence claims an intense back
and forth continued as heard faced
cross-examination by depp's attorney
camille vazquez calling into question
heard sequence of events following the
australia fight and whether she could
face perjury charges
is that your signature
yes it is and your signature appears
right under the statement quote i
declare under penalty of perjury under
the laws of the state of virginia that
the foregoing is true and correct
that is correct you right testify under
oath
while he was smashing the phone johnny
severely injured his finger cutting off
the top of it end quote did i read that
correctly yes that's correct
so you testified in this courtroom that
after mr duff smashed the phone he held
you down on the countertop by the neck
do you remember that
i'm not quite sure the exact sequence of
things but yes both of those things
happened okay
we'll get to the sequence
and this is when mr depp supposedly
assaulted you with a bottle right
on the countertop he assaulted me so mr
depp was able to get you on the counter
right
he held me down by my neck and hold you
down by your neck
that is correct and he grabbed a bottle
according to you
by holding you down by the neck correct
i'm sorry can you clarify what you're
asking me
while mr depp is holding you by the neck
against the countertop he grabs the
bottle that's your testimony no those
two things didn't happen at the exact
same time no
while he's so he's holding the bottle is
that your testimony while holding you
down by the neck sorry what was your
question
your testimonialism has heard that
either he has the bottle before or after
he's holding you by the neck on the
counter is that your testimony he held
me by the neck on the counter
where's the bottle
at what point while holding you down by
your neck
when he was assaulting me with the
bottle it was in his hand
all right joining us today is the star
of the lunch hour the infamous and
former federal prosecutor gene rossi uh
just minutes away from the courthouse
and co-host terry austin uh to discuss
this case gene how does a civil case
turn into a criminal perjury trial and
do you see that happening here in this
case
okay first did you say infamous gene
rossi or famous grc
a little bit of a little bit of b
a little bit um
first off if you have perjury alleged
perjury i'm not there yet in the perjury
but if you have perjury in a civil case
uh this goes back to president bill
clinton it is highly highly highly
unusual for a prosecutor to pick up that
that gauntlet and file criminal charges
and i am very dear friends with the head
prosecutor in fairfax county and i
trained him maybe way back in the day
he's a great great attorney there's no
way he would ever consider uh presenting
to a grand jury alleged perjury charges
against amber heard no way it's never
going to happen uh bill clinton's
investigation that was an extreme rarity
yeah i know we were discussing it before
and you're a bit of the the socrates to
to this prosecutor's plato so we're
getting it straight from the from the
from the from the wisdom for your mouth
thank you for that terry what is perjury
in virginia though and what could hurt
face if it does actually happen
well perjury is the act of lying under
oath so if she lied in a prior
deposition or if she lied on the stand
here that would be perjury and in
virginia it is a crime it's punishable
up to 10 years actually in a fine of
2500 it's a class 5 felony but you know
as gene was saying it is very difficult
to bring perjury charges because
oftentimes witnesses says
as i recall or if i remember correctly
so you really don't have the grounds to
bring the act it's hard to prove yeah so
it's the exact words that she used and i
think she's well coached by her attorney
even though the attorney doesn't seem to
know what hearsay is but on this the
perjury aspect i i think she's in the
clear thank you for the inside both of
you still ahead on law and crime daily
our comprehensive coverage of the johnny
depp versus amber her trial continues
ahead amber heard sister takes the stand
does her story line up with past
testimony
[Music]
welcome back as part of week five's
testimony jurors heard from whitney
henriquez amber hears younger sister
enriquez
backed up amber's heard's testimony
saying johnny depp hit her in his los
angeles penthouse
he comes up behind me
strikes me in the back
kind of just somewhere over here he
strikes me in the back i hear amber
shout don't hit my sister
she smacks him lands one
and then he grabs at that point that's
when travis runs up the stairs after
amber landed one and but by that time
johnny had already grabbed amber by the
hair with one hand and was whacking her
repeatedly in the face with the other
as i was standing there travis pulls
them apart i get amber into mine
i close the doors behind me and lock
them
i then hear johnny's voice shouting
never mind with character sorry i hear
johnny's voice shouting you i hate you i
hate you both you
fucking whores
and i hear crashing i hear crashing and
banging and smashing and he starts
screaming like an animal
and
i then just moved amber into the next
room and i just kept her there all night
the next day i go and i see her closet
has been completely destroyed
while enriquez's testimony backs up
herds it differs from previous testimony
of witness travis mcgivern
johnny depp's security guard who says
depp did not hit her and sister depp
himself testified similarly saying heard
through the punch
she was
coming out you know
trying to
well trying to get to me trying to hit
me
trying to do anything she could and
and then whitney her sister
was there who
who stepped in the way
and
interesting thing that was was that
what was interesting was
now
is that whitney stepped in front of
amber
and was facing amber
to stop amber
and uh
and
when she was in between us
amber
snuck in the she
reached got the
roundhouse in and and
just
nailed me on the on the cheekbone
terry as i see it i think we have some
similar stories but three different
stories mcgivern and deb seem to be very
much the same and then heard and her
sister seems to be slightly different so
what is the journey to to do with these
stories
well i think they're going to have to
parse out obviously who is more credible
who's telling the truth this was the
incident in the penthouse not long
before the tro and basically depp is
saying that he didn't hit anybody but
amber hit him and mcgivern is definitely
corroborating depth story then you have
heard and her sister and they're saying
that depp actually hit whitney and that
herd was protecting her sister and of
course that's why she hit johnny depp
but you know you have to look at how
they're telling these stories you have
to look at their credibility their body
language and i think the jury is going
to parse it out and at the end of the
day
as far as i'm concerned i'm believing
deaf right now just based on the
testimony yeah and gene that's kind of
my question to you how much value do you
think the jury will give uh enriquez
testimony maybe i'm projecting here but
i've got a baby sister perjury
definitely something i would do for her
so isn't the jury gonna think about the
same thing for for this situation
uh i'm gonna be a contrarian i love
terry but i'm going to take the other
position here i think they got into a
fight they were both hitting each other
and i agree with terry the sister has an
incredible motive to lie
to protect her for blood
but
if you look at dep's testimony and i
wonder if the jurors were taking good
notes he wasn't very detailed
uh the sister was pretty darn detailed
and she was uh
a little expressive and it didn't appear
to me even though she has a motive to
protect her sister of course it didn't
appear to me that she was just making it
all up i think there was an altercation
i think frankly they both threw punches
at each other
and uh it was a fracas that got out of
hand but i love terry but i have to be a
contrarian here it begs the question
who's the victim if both are throwing
fists because that's the heart of the
issue here but we'll figure that out as
we continue right coming up on law and
crime daily a closer look at some of
amber heard's key witnesses just ahead
hear a testimony from a top disney
executive were there plans to keep
johnny depp in the pirates of the
caribbean franchise
welcome back to law and crime daily at
the center of the johnny depp amber
heard trial are accusations of
defamation and the impact heard and
depp's words had on the other's career
on thursday video testimony from a walt
disney executive was played for the jury
she says hers washington post op-ed did
not affect depp's role in the pirates
franchise attorneys asked her about
depp's future with disney
do you have any discussions with anyone
at disney about any future pirates of
the caribbean wall a lesser or greater
role a different role or a different
production
no
did you have any discussions with anyone
at disney about the impact of the op
edvine is heard on
the relationship
between disney and mr depp including
considering mr depp for any work with
disney any future pirates of the
caribbean role a lesser or greater role
a different role or a different
production
now do you
know
whether mr depp
is being considered for a role in
pirates six i don't know one way or the
other
that decision doesn't fall within my
job responsibility it's
it's above my head
is disney aware that mr depp has
testified under oath that
he would not
take other
pirates of the caribbean franchise
rule
for 300 million dollars in a million
alpacas
now
with disney
entertain
paying mr deb more than 300 million
dollars and provide him with more than
alpacas
to be able to obtain his
uh services for any future pirates to
the caribbean wall
no
terry tina newman as you saw there was
the corporate witness for disney and we
even heard that some of the questions
were for lack of a better phrase above
her pay grade so do you think she was
qualified and prepared to present
to represent sorry the company
absolutely not she was not qualified she
is a production executive but in my
opinion she was not senior enough and
she certainly was not knowledgeable
enough in civil litigation when you have
a corporation and you call on that
corporation to testify whether it's a
notice or whether it's a subpoena the
representative is supposed to know all
of the areas that are listed in that
document she did not know the area she
did not understand in fact i've been a
corporate representative you're supposed
to be prepped on any area that you could
be asked about and saying that it's
above her pay grade i think is just not
responding properly to the document
requesting her appearance all right so i
mean gene it's it's the literally
multi-million dollar question uh did
newman's testimony then push the needle
one way or another based on her
knowledge or lack thereof of how disney
was working with johnny depp
well i'm not going to be a cartridge on
this issue terry is absolutely right
this witness i think actually helps
johnny depp and hurts amber heard
because they called the junior varsity
actually the freshman team they didn't
call anybody on the uh
varsity team and she when she made that
comment about the pay grade that said it
all and if they don't
uh stress that in closing
on the damages issue uh then they are
committing malpractice this witness did
not help amber heard my opinion yeah uh
if camille vasquez is doing the closing
arguments i doubt she's going to miss it
i know a lot of people love her through
her cross-examination but the depth team
seems to be on their p's and q's i think
they're not going to miss that point and
i agree with you gene and terry it'll be
a strong argument to make but to keep up
with the gavel to gavel coverage of the
johnny depp versus amber heard trial
make sure to follow our newest podcast
lawn crime sidebar listen in as some of
lawn crime's top hosts recap the highs
and lows of the trial so far straight
from the fairfax county courthouse in
virginia subscribe on apple podcast or
online at lawncrime.com
when we come back depp's pointing the
finger at heard and heard is pointing
the finger back at death
here's a conflicting testimony from two
experts on the ex-spouse's reputation
online
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back our comprehensive coverage
of the johnny depp amber her defamation
trial continues as a social media expert
takes the stand tying damage to herd's
reputation to comments made by one of
depp's lawyers that her accusations of
abuse were a hoax
i
looked
through tweets that were negative
towards ms heard and i found that a
super majority of them were using one of
four different hashtags
and so overall what did your analysis
find regarding negative hashtags about
his herd from april 2020
until the end of january 2021
well there were
over 1 million 243 000 and change
the uses of those hashtags during that
time frame you just mentioned some of
these hashtags are are pretty rude and
uh
it
would really surprise me that anyone
would think that they wouldn't be you
reviewed a number of hashtags that you
deemed were negative towards misheard
that's right yes yeah and the four
you picked at least the negative ones
uh justice for johnny depp
that's one of them right that's right
amber heard as an abuser
that's one of them that is one of them
we just don't like you amber
that's one of them that is one of them
and the last one was amber turd right
that's that is another one justice for
johnny depp is not negative towards
misheard is it
no but the tweets that use that hashtag
are
you may remember three weeks ago an
analyst an analytics expert testified
for a depth team saying depp's
reputation took a negative turn after
her 2016 abuse allegations and again
after the 2018 opt ed
i wanted to analyze the q scores during
this snapshot of time i wanted to
understand what they were before
during and after the op-ed and what this
tells me is his positive q score went
from a 35 to a 29
and then his negative went from an 11 to
a 15. so what the q scores is telling me
is the public perception of mr depp uh
has been damaged you know they
they like him less and they dislike him
more my opinions are that you know mr
depp was not portrayed in a negative
connotation prior to the 2016
allegations of abuse
and then mr depp's
image he was portrayed in a negative
connotation after the 2016 allegations
of abuse and then more so
after the 2018 washington post op-ed
uh and then the q scores represent that
uh you know the public thinks he's
damaged
gene you've been following this case
closely you've even reported from
outside the courtroom i understand
you're just a stone throws away from the
court but with all of the evidence
presented so far do you think depp lost
opportunities because of the op-ed or
something else
oh i think it was uh probably uh 25 was
attributed to the op-ed the other 75
was his reputation from way back in 2009
and there was that one witness uh for
the uh heard team
that said his uh reputation was going
downhill was a slippery slope that was
becoming a luge uh because he was late
he appeared to be intoxicated he was
difficult to handle
his crew started to dislike him this is
way before
the op-ed article so the op-ed hurt him
but i think 75 percent was things that
happened before the op-ed and if that's
the case if gene rossi's right that's
not good on his damage's claim yeah
we'll see how that plays out terry ron
chanel's testimony was somewhat
technical do you think depp's team made
any progress with the cross
examination i do think they made some
progress look if the jury goes away with
just a couple of points i think that the
cross-examination will have been
effective we know that the hoax comments
by waldman who is dep's attorney those
were all in august of 2020 and i think
depp's team was able to establish that
those four hashtags justice for deaf
heard as an abuser we just don't like
you amber and amber turd those hashtags
started before the comments and the
other issue is
this was only a mathematical correlation
the expert could not say that it was
related to any article all right that's
true well one hashtag you should be
following is law and crime and law and
crime daily of course but thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you